.
>> AND REPUBLICAN WHO'S SUPPORT
TRUMP ON CAPITOL HILL ARE REALLY
UP IN ARMS ABOUT THIS.
THAT RAID AT MAR-A-LAGO.
LET'S REMIND OUR VIEWERS WHAT
CONGRESSMAN MIKE TURNER OF OHIO,
THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, TOLD US
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE SKEPTICISM
OF BOTH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IN ORDER FOR THEM TO HAVE
CREDIBILITY, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
AN UNBELIEVABLE LEVEL OF BIAS.
THIS IS PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
POLITICAL RIVAL.
PERHAPS EVEN HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
CERTAINLY HIS PAST POLITICAL
>> -- IN ANY WAY.
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
GARLAND HASN'T TOLD US.
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO ASK
GARLAND.
WHETHER OR NOT HE DID TELL THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYING ABOUT THE SUGGESTION
CONGRESSMAN TURNER IS MAKING
THAT THIS IS A POLITICAL
VENDETTA LED BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND.
>> WELL, FIRST HE DOES NOT
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
MATTER.
HE HELD THE RARE PRESS
CONFERENCE AND SAID HE CAN'T
TAKE QUESTIONS.
HE NEEDS TO REMAIN SILENT FOR
THE SAKE OF THE INVESTIGATION
BEYOND WHAT THEY REVEALED ABOUT
PURSUING THE RELEASE OF THE
SEARCH WARRANT.
THEY SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN DID
NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS IN ADVANCE.
THEN HE FOUND OUT ON MEDIA
REPORTS AND ON TELEVISION WHEN
IT WAS FIRST REPORTED.
THEY'RE STRONGLY PUSHING BACK ON
THE IDEA THAT THIS HAS ANY
POLITICAL MOTIVATION BEHIND IT.
THEY'VE SAID THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ON ITS OWN IS DOING
THIS INVESTIGATION
INDEPENDENTLY.
THEY'VE HIGHLIGHTED THAT.
THEY'VE NOTED THAT IT WAS A
FEDERAL COURT THAT APPROVED THE
SEARCH WARRANT AT TRUMP'S HOUSE.
THAT WAS BASED UPON THE REQUIRED
FINDING OF PROBABLE CAUSE PFRLT
BASICALLY MEANS IT WASN'T
GARLAND HIMSELF SIGNING OFF ON
THIS, THOUGH HE DID PERSONALLY
SIGN OFF ON IT.
IT WAS A COURT THAT SAID THEY
DID BELIEVE THERE WAS A REASON
FOR FBI AGENTS TO GO TO
MAR-A-LAGO AND LOOK AND RETRIEVE
THESE DOCUMENTS.
SO THEY'RE SAYING IT IS NOT JUST
BIDEN AND GARLAND BASICALLY
MAKING THIS DECISION, JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US TO DISCUSS, THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINSINGER.
I WANT TO START RID THERE WITH
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM YOUR
COLLEAGUE, MIKE TURNER,
SUGGESTING THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH
MAY HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY GARLAND
AND BIDEN BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
EVENTS.
THAT IS TO ACKNOWLEDGE HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANY EVIDENCE TO
THAT FACT BUT SAID THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ANSWERED.
HE IS THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
>> IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
INTERESTING TO ME.
THESE PEOPLE THAT YOU WORKED
WITH FOR A LONG TIME COME OUT
WITH THESE THEORIES THAT YOU'RE
LIKE, WHERE DID THAT COME FROM?
YOU'RE A VERY SERIOUS PERSON.
LOOK.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK HAPPENS IN A
LOT OF CASES.
THIS IS THE FBI SITUATION WITH
THE REPUBLICANS.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS THAT
KNOW DONALD TRUMP IS A LIAR.
THEY KNOW HE IS INSANE.
THEY STAY KIND OF QUIET.
THEY'RE A LITTLE CROSSWISE WITH
THEIR BASE.
THEY'RE NOT DEFENDING DONALD
TRUMP HARD ENOUGH.
THEN YOU GET THIS ISSUE LIKE THE
FBI AND THEY SEE IT AS THEIR
OUTLET WHERE THEY CAN FIGHT HARD
FOR TRUMP.
MAKE THEIR BASE HAPPY.
AND IT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING.
THE PROBLEM IS IT IS REALLY
DANGEROUS.
OUR PARTY WAS OUTRAGED WHEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA AT ONE POINT
SAID, I FORGET, THERE WAS A
PROFESSOR THAT THE POLICE CAME
TO HIS HOUSE AND HE SAID THE
POLICE ACTED STUPIDLY.
HE SAID THAT BEFORE KNOWING
OUGHT DETAILS.
OUR PARTY WAS OUTRAGED.
NOW A FEW SHORT YEARS LATER
WE'RE LEVELING ACCUSATION THAT'S
THE FBI IS IN SOME DEEP STATE
PLOT THE TAKE TRUMP DOWN.
IF TRUMP IS SO TOUGH, IF HE'S SO
GOOD AT EVERYTHING HE DOES, HOW
HAS HE BEEN SUCH A VICTIM OF THE
DEEP STATE SO MANY TIMES?
BECAUSE HE'S NOT.
BECAUSE HE USES VICTIMIZATION AS
HIS WAY OUT.
AND IT IS REALLY FRUSTRATING AND
SAD TO SEE MY PARTY HAVING GONE
DOWN SUCH A DARK PATH.
>> CONGRESSMAN TURNER TOLD ME HE
WANTS THE AFFIDAVIT BEHIND THE
MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH RELEASED.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS UNTIL
NEXT THURSDAY TO TELL THE JUDGE
HOW MUCH OF THAT DOCUMENT THEY
NEED TO BE REDACTED.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
IS THERE A DANGER THAT BY WITH
HOLDING TOO MUCH INFORMATION,
THAT COULD UNDERMAIN PUBLIC
FAITH IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
EVEN FURTHER?
>> YEAH.
IT IS A UNIQUE MOMENT.
BY THE WAY THOUGH, I THINK NO
MATTER WHAT COMES OUT, IT IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO CHANGE
SOME PEOPLE'S MINDS.
I THINK THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT SAY, I KNOW DONALD
TRUMP IS LYING.
I JUST DON'T CARE ANYMORE.
I'M JUST ALL IN WITH TRUMP.
HE CAN LIE ALL HE WANTS.
I DO THINK IN THE INTERESTS OF
KIND OF NATIONAL SECURITY, OF
DOMESTIC POLITICS, YOU KNOW,
TRANSPARENCY IS GOOD BUT LET'S
KEEP IN MIND.
FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY REPORTED ON OPEN
SOURCE, THERE IS SOME STUFF THAT
IS SO CLASSIFIED YOU CAN'T EVEN
SAY WHAT IT IS.
IF THAT IS THE CASE, CERTAINLY
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
NOT REVEALING THAT EVEN IN AN
AFFIDAVIT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
PUTTING ANYBODY'S LIFE AT RISK.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
WE'RE REDACTING THINGS, WE'RE
NOT DOING IT IN A WAY THAT
PEOPLE CAN USE THAT AS A
CONSPIRACY AS WELL.
WE LIVE IN A MOMENT WHERE WE
HAVE TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY FROM
THE LAW.
PEOPLE WILL HAVE THEIR OWN
THEIRIES ALL THE TIME NO MATTER
WHAT IT IS.
AND THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WILL
FOLLOW DONALD TRUMP INTO THE
SWAMP BECAUSE THEY JUST LOVE HIM
SO MUCH.
>> TODAY THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE ASKS SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ADDRESS THIS SURGE OF
VIOLENT THREATS BEING MADE
AGAINST LAW ENFORCEMENT EVER
SINCE THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH.
TO WHAT DEGREE DO YOU BLAME NOT
ONLY TRUMP BUT SOME OF YOUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
ATTACKED THE FBI IN DEFENSE OF
TRUMP?
CRITICISM OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTION IS ONE THING.
BUT SUGGESTING THAT THE FBI
SHOULD BE DEFUNDED, SUGGESTING
REVEALING THE NAME OF INDIVIDUAL
FBI AGENTS, ET CETERA, THAT'S A
DIFFERENT STEP.
>> IT REALLY IS.
KEEP IN MIND THERE ARE PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE PLACE NOW THAT
THINK THE FBI IS THIS DEEP STATE
CONSPIRACY.
FBI AGENTS ARE GOING TO WORK.
THEY'RE KISSING THEIR FAMILIES
GOODBYE IN THE MORNING.
THEY'RE DOING THEIR JOB.
THEY'RE COMING HOME.
MANY OF THEM ARE REPUBLICANS.
NOT THAT THAT THE MATTERS.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT SUPPORTING
DONALD TRUMP TO THE ENDS OF THE
EARTH.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO GETS HURT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO GETS IN
HIS WAY.
HE DOESN'T CARE HAD A GETS IN
HIS WAY AND GETS HURT.
WHEN YOU'RE SUCH A DEEP
NARCISSIST TO THAT LEVEL, YOU
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE DAMAGE.
ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA SIDE, I HATE
TO SAY WE NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD.
WE HAVE TO COME TO THE A
CONCLUSION OF WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA
ISN'T RESPONSIBLE FOR.
I'M ALL FOR THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
WHAT I'M NOT FOR IS INSURRECTION
TYPE, VIOLENT TYPE SPEECH BEING
PROMOTED, PASSED ON IN THESE
MEDIUMS THAT CAN LEAD TO A
REALLY DESTABILIZED SITUATION.
I RETWEETED SOME GUY THAT POSTED
A BUNCH OF TIKTOK PHOTOS OF GUYS
WITH THEIR GUNS SAYING IT IS
TIME TO GO AFTER THE GOVERNMENT.
I'M GOING AFTER THE FBI.
IT IS ALL OVER TIKTOK.
IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THESE 50,
60-YEAR-OLD MEN ON TIKTOK.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE HAVE TO
DISCUSS.
THAT CAN'T BE ALLOWED ANYMORE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> I WANT TO TURN TO ANOTHER
TRUMP INVESTIGATION.
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING IS PART OF
THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE.
YOU'VE BEEN GOING BACK AND FORTH
WITH FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO ABOUT SOME MATTERS.
I WANT TO FOCUS YOU ABOUT WHAT
HE SAID ABOUT HIS INTERVIEW WITH
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY WERE CHASING WITCHES,
RIGHT?
THIS WAS A FAR AFIELD WANDERING
INTERVIEW.
I SPOKE TO TRUTH TO THEM.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THE DETAILS.
THEY WERE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE 25th
AMENDMENT, DISCUSSIONS THAT I
NEVER SERIOUSLY UNDERTOOK WITH
ANY OF MY COUNTER PARTS.
THEY WERE LOOKING TO BUILD A
STORY LINE, THE CONCLUSION OF
WHICH WAS ALREADY WRITTEN.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, LOOK, I CAN'T REVEAL
WHAT HE TALKED GOING BUT LET ME
SAY THERE ABOUT MAKE.
WE'RE FRIENDS.
WE WORKED TOGETHER IN CONGRESS.
HE WAS AS HAWKISH AS I AM.
VERY MUCH A BELIEVER IN WHAT IT
STOOD FOR.
HE BECAME SECRETARY OF STATE AND
DID ALL OF DONALD TRUMP'S
BIDDING.
HE WROTE THE DEAL WITH THE
TALIBAN, AND THEN HE'S TRYING TO
PIN THIS ALL ON BIDEN.
I BLAME JOE BIDEN FOR WHAT
HAPPENED IN AFGHANISTAN.
I ALSO BLAME MIKE POMPEO.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO KICK A SIDE
HERE.
THEY'RE ALL TO BLAME.
AND HE'S TRYING TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
HE WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE KNOWS THAT HE CANNOT GO AFTER
TRUMP AND RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE'S HOPING TRUMP WILL RUN AND
HE CAN USE THAT LANE.
THAT IS SOMEONE WITHOUT A MORAL
CENTER.
AND HE HAD A MORAL CENTER.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WHEN HE WENT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT I GUESS POWER
IS VERY, VERY ATTRACTIVE TO SOME
PEOPLE.
AS THEY ALWAYS SAY, POWER
CORRUPTS.
AND IT IS SAD TO SEE MY FRIEND
GONE THE WAY HE'S GONE.
IF HE COULD JUST TELL THE TRUTH.
I KNOW DID HE SO